anthony munoz being added to the brand
new bengals ring of honor along with
paul brown team founder they're gonna
name two more as well they think ken
anderson is gonna be one of those two
additional uh members charter members of
the ring of honor anthony munoz hopes
that the bengals with the fifth overall
pick in this year's draft will take
penny sewell what a shock left tackle
wants the bengals to take a left tackle
i would say starting quarterback would
very much like the bengals to take a
left tackle so he has a better chance of
of avoiding the kind of devastating knee
injury that he suffered in his rookie
year so no brainer and the bengals are
in a great spot at number five they
essentially have
because they wouldn't take a quarterback
anyway it's like having the second
overall pick in the draft behind the
falcons and if the falcons take a
quarterback it's like having the first
overall pick in the draft because this
is who if it goes quarterback
quarterback quarterback quarterback
which would be awesome if it happens
it's great news for the bengals because
they've got pick one in the draft in the
five slot
because it's the guy they would have
taken first overall and maybe it will be
sewell maybe it'll be a receiver but
they're in a position to get a great
player who can come in and help build
around the franchise quarterback not
just in herbert that was sewell's
teammate at oregon but joe barrow the
guy who was the first overall pick last
year so this is a great development for
the bengals whoever they take all this
quarterback top talk at the top of the
draft is good good news for the
cincinnati bengals miles
no doubt and you know i think that if
you are the cincinnati bengals or the
one thing i would object to that you
just said is that it's a no-brainer i
don't know that it's a no-brainer that
they will take penny sewell because they
also have a guy that's gonna be there in
jamar chase who was so so good with joe
burrow the year that they won that
national championship in 2019 so i if
the reporting has been that joe burrow
has been in the year of duke tobin maybe
he's saying some things about how good
chase can be on that offense and you
pair them with t higgins who knows how
good they can be really so i think that
that's one thing that if they aren't
going to take sewell then that's
probably who they would go with but if
it's me
and if i just came off a devastating
knee injury i would want that left
tackle especially with a guy who as he
said plays with the kind of violent
intentions that he does at left tackle
but yeah i mean you look at jamar chase
look at everything he did he deserves to
be a top five top eight pick
i agree with you and look i'm sorry if i
misspoke it's a no-brainer they're gonna
get a guy that's gonna make the team
better i didn't mean to say it's a
no-brainer they're gonna take sewell
whether it's chase whether it's devontae
smith what you doubt me are you doubting
me is that what you're doing i am that
is what i'm doing because it's not
really what you said at all i'm sorry
i'm sorry if that's what i said well i
apologize i'm still under the influence
of propofol that's my excuse and again
you had your chance to wally pit me
yesterday and you blew it and i wasn't
given the opportunity well you engineer
the opportunity you make things happen
you work behind the scenes a little
skullduggery a little a little uh a
little sabotage a little cloak and
dagger and see all's fair you gotta have
some machiavelli in you to make it in
this business kid all right i'm just
kidding uh unless i'm not
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports